we know the US is running a relatively
large trade deficit relative to China in
2009 we imported two hundred and sixty
billion more than we exported to China
and we know from the last few videos
that the way the way that China is
keeping their currency from appreciating
because of this trade imbalances that
they're going out they're printing money
and using that UN to buy dollar assets
and we see over here in 2006 2007 2008
major increases in US assets but what's
a little bit more interesting is that in
2009 we didn't have a huge increase it's
pretty large by any standard but not
large enough to offset the actual trade
imbalance so how did China keep its
currency peg even better let's actually
look at because this isn't just the
Chinese government these are these are
just ownership of US assets by Chinese
nationals but we can actually look at
the major foreign holders of Treasury
securities this actually comes from the
Treasury's own website and it tells us
how much different central banks are how
much how many Treasury securities they
are actually holding you could see China
is the biggest holder it is the biggest
holder if you go to November of 2009 it
has 929
billion dollars this is the People's
Bank of China has 929
billion dollars worth of US Treasuries
but what's interesting here it is the
largest holder but as we go from
November of 2009 to November of 2010
their holdings actually went down not by
a ton they're still right around 900
billion but they went down so given the
fact that we have this trade deficit
given the fact that they want to peg
their currency and that they want to
print money and go buy other people's
assets how did this happen how did the
number of Treasuries actually go down
and actually how did they how are they
able to reduce the amount of all US
assets that they bought now the Treasury
answer is they don't have to just buy
Treasuries they could buy other US
assets but even over here we saw that
they didn't buy a ton of other US assets
and
clue to what's happening here and this
won't this isn't exactly what's
necessarily happening it's far more
complicated than I can explain in one
video is that we do see other countries
whose US Treasury holdings are
increasing dramatically over the course
of 2010 in particular you see the United
Kingdom you see the United Kingdom their
holdings have grown from 155 billion to
500 billion over the course of 2010 and
this is relative the United Kingdom does
not have a significant trade and balance
one way or the other with the United
States and we actually see we actually
see that its currency really didn't
change much over the course of 2010 it's
been about it's been about the same and
this looks more dramatic than it really
is
so the answer and it could be much more
complicated and this is that China has
decided to somewhat diversify from
buying US Treasuries and in particular
US assets and maybe they're diversifying
it to the pound sterling maybe they're
diversifying to the euro and so they
will start buying they will start buying
say British assets but the British don't
want their currency to appreciate too
much because then they'll suffer trade
consequences their goods will be too
expensive and so the British central
bank would then want to maybe so that
their currency does not appreciate
relative to the dollar they'll want to
go and buy American assets and that's
what it looks like it's actually
happening and maybe one other small
point is that the Chinese government has
slowly allowed its currency to
appreciate but this isn't the the
appreciation isn't as dramatic as this
chart makes it look this is six point
eight six point eight and when to the
dollar at the beginning of 2010 to about
six point six if we're not getting close
to zero here this is just from six point
eight to six point six but over the last
several years they have slowly been
allowing their currency to appreciate
but what's really happening is that
they're diversifying away from dollar
assets but when they buy those other
currencies those people are going to
want to buy dollar assets to keep their
currency from moving too much